good evening
ladies and gentlemen
we are tonight's entertainment
i only have one question where is
harvey dent
you know where harvey is you know who he
is hands up pretty boy
do you know where i can find harvey i
need to talk to him about something just
something little huh
no what's going on out there
wait oh thank god you've got a panic
room
hey wait uh you gotta be kidding me
you know i'll settle for his loved ones
we're not intimidated by
thugs you know
you remind me of my father
i hated my father okay stop
well hello beautiful
you must be harvey's squeeze
and you are beautiful
well you look nervous is it the scars
you want to know how i got them
come here hey welcome man
so i had a wife she was beautiful thank
you
who tells me i worry too much
who tells me i ought to smile more
who gambles and gets in deep with the
sharks
okay one day they carve her face
we have no money for surgeries she can't
take it
i just want to see her smile again
[Music]
i just want her to know that i don't
care about the scars
so i stick a raisin in my mouth
and do this to myself
and you know what she can't stand the
size of me
she leaves now i see the funny side
now i'm always smiling
a little fighting you i like that
then you're gonna love me
drop the gun oh sure you just take off
your little mask and show us all who you
really are
let her go very poor choice of words
all right
let's not do that again is harvey okay
he's safe
thank you
you